A tick is one of the most
dangerous things on the planet.
Even though it may not look like it.
A single bite could affect you
for the rest of your life.
But how can this happen exactly?
On today's challenge,
we're going to show you
what happens when you get
bitten by a tick.
Ticks are not insects.
They're parasitic arachnids
that can be as small as
a poppyseed.
They are capable of
carrying more diseases
than any other arthropod.
But not all ticks are disease carriers.
The most common
disease-transmitting species is
the black-legged tick,
also known as the deer tick.
What if
a disease-ridden deer tick bit you?
How quickly would you feel the effects,
if at all?
You're hiking through a meadow of
tall grass on a warm spring day.
Little do you know that
it's prime tick season,
and you'll be bringing home a stowaway.
Ticks don't always latch on right away.
They sometimes spend
an hour or two searching
for the perfect place to feast,
often where there is thin skin
near a blood vessel.
When a tick finally finds
the perfect place to extract your blood,
it burrows its head into your skin.
It unleashes a feeding tube
and secretes blood-thinning,
skin-numbing saliva.
Not only did it bite you,
but you didn't even feel it.
Yuck.
The tick has likely been feeding on
a moist area on your body,
like your groin or armpits.
And by now,
the tick is much larger
than a poppyseed,
having gorged on your blood
for over 24 hours.
There are many diseases
transmitted by ticks,
like the Powassan virus and
the Rocky Mountain spotted fever.
But the most well-known
tick-borne ailment
is Lyme disease.
A 2014 study found that
only one to three percent of people
bitten by a tick carrying Lyme disease
will become infected.
But the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention says
the number of reported
cases of Lyme disease
in the United States
has tripled since the late 1990s.
Luckily, disease transmission
is not instantaneous.
The CDC says that if the tick is
removed within 24 hours,
your chances of
getting Lyme disease are low.
Unfortunately,
you continue to go about your day,
not realizing that
there's a blood-sucking parasite
attached to your body.
You've finally noticed the tick
as it has become engorged
and grown to three times
its original size.
That's nasty.
Now it's time to remove it.
Get some tweezers and grasp the tick
close to your skin's surface.
Pull straight up and away from the skin,
applying steady pressure.
Do not bend or twist the tick.
Next, check the bite site to see if
any of the tick’s head remains
and carefully remove it.
Clean the bite with soap and water.
Then submerge the tick
in rubbing alcohol
to make sure it's dead.
You'd notice a solid red oval that
looks like a bulls-eye at the bite site.
Meh, it's probably nothing.
It'll go away in a couple of days, right?
The tick debacle is behind you.
But much to your dismay,
it left a sinister parting gift.
The red bulls-eye remains
at the bite site.
You've developed a full-body rash.
And over the past four weeks,
you've had persistent headaches,
neck stiffness,
and aches everywhere.
Plus, you're nauseous.
As the month has progressed,
you're experiencing a fever and chills.
You notice that
your lymph nodes are swollen.
You assume it's just a bug
and not the blood-sucking,
disease-carrying kind.
So you take some painkillers
and ride it out.
After months,
your symptoms have gotten
even worse.
On top of feeling sick all the time,
you've also had a hard time
concentrating and remembering things.
You've finally decided to see a doctor.
You've been diagnosed with
Lyme disease.
If you spotted this tick six months ago
and went to the doctor right away,
this disease would've been
easier to treat.
You may not have even gotten it
in the first place.
You’ll need antibiotics right away.
Luckily there is hope
you'll get back to normal.
But it could be a long road to recovery.
Even after antibiotics,
people who have Lyme disease
can experience symptoms
for up to six months.
But if you seek medical attention,
you will eventually recover.
"I got better!"
Hopefully, you can avoid
something like this happening.
After all,
the key to preventing Lyme disease
is making sure a tick never latches
onto you in the first place.
When exploring the outdoors,
wear long pants
with socks pulled up over your ankles.
After you get home,
check for ticks,
especially on your head,
legs,
and ankles.
And don't forget to check your pets.
A tick bite can affect them as well.
Although getting a tick bite
can come with
some serious consequences,
you did manage to survive.
But what about another challenge
with a far lower survival rate,
like being allergic to everything?
Well,
we'll see what that challenge brings
on the next episode of